each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
I'm very pleased to introduce the
bastion Burkhardt to you he is visiting
us from the University of Pennsylvania
where he's been working towards his PhD
with the professor and professor martin
his thesis work is on automatic
verification of tricky concurrent data
structures and while prior work has
worked on this problem occasionally on
verifying it for sequentially consistent
memory model Milo is perhaps the first
one to really push in the direction of
verifying these kind of data structures
for weaker memory models and that's what
he's going to tell us about today okay
thank you for the introduction I don't
think I need to say anything more for
these first sites that we can start so
the general motivation has to back up a
step the general motivation is that
shared memory multiprocessors are taking
over the world in the sense that
architecture is pushing those things
with the multi-core processors and our
ability to write the software for those
things is kind of lagging behind so what
happens is if you have concurrent
executions of multi-threaded software
own shared memory multiprocessor we end
up with lots of box and the perfect
reason is that verification is really
quite hard this is true in general not
just for my specific area here so the
problem is the tests are not good at
finding all inter leavings these
executions are very non deterministic
and the reasoning is a lot more
challenging for concurrent programs than
for sequential programs and it wasn't
easy for sequential programs to start
with now the standard strategy is of
course this is what we are taught in
classes of our concurrent programming is
to use logs to restrict the concurrent
access is specifically we don't want
rights to erase with reads or writes to
race with rights that's when you have to
use logs and just makes it easier to
verify so there are fewer intro leavings
there's a clear or reasoning based on
mutual exclusion and we can use tools to
find the races but logs also have the
drawback so there are some
once it looks like introduce deadlocks
so one good question is what do you do
after you too will find the race and
what's the solution and you know if you
just insert locks then you may end up
with a deadlock so it's not in general
easy to find a good locking strategy for
a program so locks can hurt performance
because you basically restrict the
concurrency so if you have a single lock
protecting the entire program then you
get no concurrency at all only one
processor can execute at a time and
locks are also not robust so the problem
is if it's red fails while it holds a
lock then not nobody else can keep
working and there's also dangerous and
if you have interrupt so this is more an
operating system level if you interrupt
this red holding a lock you get into
trouble so what are the alternatives now
one big alternative would be
transactional memory but I'm not talking
about that so let's look at other things
so here is a basically what I see as a
promise and the problem is that promise
so concurrency libraries I think are a
good way to simplify the programming of
multiple processors so there are two
things that are good about such
libraries they simplify the development
in the sense that the programmer can use
building blocks that are already
verified they can also building blocks
can already be optimized so in
particular there have been these
implementations of lock free data types
and clearly if it there's nothing wrong
in the eye with the idea of having
things like queues or sets that don't
use locks at all it will be perfect for
program if you could just use those
structures the problem is they're really
hard to actually write so how does that
work the problem really is that the
optimizations like this lock freeness
introduce a lot of complexity and there
is one more thing that makes it
difficult to build those things which is
that the multiprocessors use relaxed
memory models and I'm going to talk more
about that in the following so what I'm
attempting to do here is really trying
to bring a couple different areas
together to make it work so we have on
the architecture side we have the
multiprocessors and we have to relax
memory models on the distributed
algorithms side we have people coming up
with tricky algorithms that are you know
promise much better performance that
don't use locks which all sounds very
great and the third aisle here is we
have computer aided verification which
we know has made a lot of progress and
is able to model check the code and can
give sound counter-examples as an
important tool of getting things right
so what we're trying to do here is
bringing other things together so we
bring this together in form of a tool
called Jack fans and the methodology of
this tool will be discussing two
publications in Calvin pldi so let me go
into an example so here we have a client
program which educates in multiple
processors so that's the premise of this
talk today we really talk multiple
processors not just multiple threads and
this disc line program makes calls to a
data type which is a queue in this case
say this cause n qn q DQ DQ I'm sure you
recognize this as you know consumer
producer pattern very frequently done
like that and here we have the
implementation which provides the code
for each operation and the trick here
there are no locks now how can we do
that how can we do this right with and
it locks actually it's very difficult so
there is a publication of this this is
not the only algorithm but it's a good
one to to take I only show you one of
the two operations namely the DQ
operation and you can you can see
there's a lot going on here so the basic
idea is simple it's a linked list with
head and tail pointers but getting this
to work is actually very tricky so
there's a lot I don't expect you to read
through this and understand it I don't
think it's possible to do that but I can
give you some highlights so there are
comparing swap operations used instead
of locks and there are some relaxations
going on like the tail pointer is
allowed to lag behind the actual pale we
can't always guarantee that it's
pointing at the actual tail and the
program does tricks like here it reads
the head of the queue and he retreated
again and compares it to the previously
right value so those are like the kind
of tricks that these people use and the
whole thing is wrapped in a loop which
is a reprieve so you try to do this and
if you sometimes you detect that
something is wrong then you start over
well you have to eat the paper too
to find out exactly how this works but
it's very tricky now what is the
expectation of the programmer on this
the expectations basically is you want
this to work as if it was sequentially
consistent so what that means is the
program observes this the client program
sees the operations it sees the values
that are passed in and the values that
come out and what you want is this
observation has to be consistent with
some interleaving of the operations so
you require that for all observations
there should be some witness into
leaving that produces those results that
you're actually seeing so that's all
that the programmer at this point that's
all that the programmer wants maybe
there will be more at some point now
what's the problem here so the client
program wants sequential consistency the
problem is the underlying hardware is
not so generous so there's no guarantee
that the hardware actually on its level
gives the credential consistent so it's
the job of the implementation to hide
the relaxations in the hardware from the
programmer now what are the hardware
relaxations so this is an example of
what goes wrong on a multiprocessor when
you work with loads and stores so I have
an execution here processor one writes
value 1 to X rights value to 2y
processor two reads here something is
wrong about this execution I try to
point it out what it is it is there is
no witness in delivering why not so i'll
show you queen arrows that mean this
should happen before this in any
interleaving so clearly by the
definition of interleaving you want
things to appear in program order so
this should happen before this and this
should happen before that now there's
more arrows because here we read the
value Y and get to so clearly this Reed
has to happen after this store but
there's one more here we read zero so
this Reed has to happen before this
store otherwise it would read one and
you see we have we have a cycle so this
is not a sequentially consistent
execution now this is a reality on
multiprocessors for software to work
right on the sub
Constance's you need additional
instructions called memory fences which
allow you basically to restrict the
hardware in its reordering of
instructions so let me do a little bit
of background on relaxed memory models
what platforms use relaxed memory models
the answer is most so includes in Intel
both regular x86 and titanium PowerPC
spark alpha c6 that'sthat's the
mainframes a good question would be why
doesn't everything break like if you
start reordering loads and stores why
doesn't everything break that's a very
good question the answer is I mean first
of all single threaded programs are not
affected all these relaxations are
designed to be invisible to single
threaded programs but also this is very
important here raise free programs are
not affected so if you do what you're
told in class and use locks to protect
every access you're actually safe you
won't ever see these relaxations there's
actually very good reason to follow you
know the lock lock based programming
model now the problem is for the
implementations that we look at there
are races they use races on purpose for
better performance so unfortunately they
are exposed to relax memory models now
what's the challenge for the
verification here so the challenge is
that the number of executions grows and
grows if you have finer grained
concurrency so if you start with serial
executions this is basically the model
there each operation is protected by one
lock you do the whole thing you
interleave on the operation boundary
then you don't have so many executions
now if you go away from locks then you
interleaved instructions of the
different threads on an instruction
order you get a lot more executions but
with relaxed memory models it gets even
worse because now not only do you
interleave the different threads but you
also start splitting instructions and
reordering instructions within a thread
so this makes the verification a lot
harder how do we verify something like
that so there are a couple of problems
is existing tools so we don't really
have a model checker that can handle
relaxed models we would be forced to
make each instruction in two separate
process the correctness condition also
is not supported in this form so there
is no tool right now that checks
sequential consistency of data type and
we have the problem that we actually
should support the features that appear
in those implementations so we need to
handle dynamic memory pointers arrays
structs and so on which is done I mean a
lot of tools exist that dude have this
ability to handle details of this kind
unfortunately those tools are written
for sequential programs so that was the
first part now I'll get to my solution
or our solution i should say of course
there's a lot of work yes you said
before they give you as long as you use
logs you're okay yeah doesn't mean that
the thread blocks anything at all or
what are the conditions are different
restrictions on how you use to log store
doesn't mean that as long as you have
any law operation everything is okay
well that there is a definition of what
is a race so using locks correctly means
there are no data races meaning that
whenever you have to access is one of at
least one of which is the right to the
same memory location they must be
ordered by synchronization instructions
meaning a lock or non la cooperación now
yeah that's taught yeah so there is the
question how did the reason why it works
is that you have in the lock and in the
unlock operations to or memory fences
which will guarantee enough memory
ordering for you to be safe but there
are some complications if you log if you
not have not only lock and unlock but
out something like you know tentatively
acquire a lock that may lead to problems
if you use something like that the
hardware doesn't know when you acquire a
lock the hardware doesn't know which
memory locations that lock is supposed
to put yeah so the guarantee really
doesn't work by the hardware knowing
about the locks the guarantee works
because inside the lock operation there
is a fence and inside the unlock
operation
there's another fence so those fences
are enough to guarantee the necessary
ordering of instructions so then it
seems like just blocking anything at all
would yes correct okay yes okay so this
is the way I have structured our tool so
we have here the C code for the data
operations and now this thing needs a
little explanation because we work with
tests so what is a symbolic test in this
case well for a queue it can it would
look something like this this is a
simple one I have two threads one dozen
can run the CD command you see I have
symbolic values for the arguments that
are passed in and for the values
returned so those are the inputs to the
tool I also select the memory to memory
model that I want to verify this for and
the answer of the tool can either pass
or fail pass will be accompanied by a
witness which is just one example
execution of the program of the test or
it can be a fail plus counter example
and the tail the fail would basically
show in execution where the observed
results meaning the evaluations to these
values x and y are not consistent with
with any sequential execution of these
operations basket so the witness that
sometimes so the reason why I do a
witness is if you if you start putting
things in like assumes in your test
cases which is an option you have then
you made up with vacuous execution
meaning that there is no execution at
all and you want to catch that because
that's not that's actually a mistake in
your test framework that you want to
find out about so that's why I basically
do not only solve for failing executions
but I also solve for at least one
passing execution to make sure that the
resource you know this is purely a
service if you want to look at one
counseling execution yeah so what I just
ask me that every interleaving of the
test has a corresponding sequentially
consistent
yes so internally what I do is the
following so I take the C code and run
it through the steel front end so my
ability to handle see actually relies on
a lot of work that other people have
done for me which gives me cleaned up
input from a tool the symbolic test goes
in here as well in here I take those two
things and create a satin coding and
with the SATs all right look for an
execution which violates the conditions
and if I find it I format the trace that
we can look at and there's some magic
going on here with lo pans and
specification that I'll talk about later
so I want to start with the demo so this
is a remote session on some computer and
i want to show you basically what goes
into the test and what comes out of the
tool so we have a cup of files here
let's start with the actual code so you
can see this is just standard c code
here we have some data structures
defined the queue data type and in order
to our individual nodes of the queue
this is a to lock you so it's not lock
free but it does have raises has a lock
for the head and for the tail and down
here we have the operations we don't
need to look at this in detail I just
want to give you an impression so here
is the enqueue operation down here the
DQ operation now we want to test this so
these are the tests that you want to run
so this notation is brief so test t0
here first initializes the queue and
then this means concurrently executing
thread so I have two threads here one
doing 1nq and wandering 1dq operation
test for TB c4 down here PPC is for test
producer-consumer has one thread doing
four anchors in a sequence and then for
DQ's the other thread doing for
decreasing sequence so i try to make
this yes why does I mean initialize ok
I'll show you it's the next next thing
ya so there's something missing here
that would be magic wouldn't it so
there's something called harness so this
is the connection between the tests and
the actual program so what I do here is
I mean those are the letters that we had
before but here you know for the enqueue
i actually create a non-deterministic
value so in this case i choose a range
between 0 and 1 which will be symbolic
in the encoding and they also annotate
these observe things so I have to make
somehow clear what is what is to observe
what is the API of the data type so if
we see it's not as automatic as you may
think knowing what is actually being
passed into a procedure and what's
coming out you need to specify that in
some way in this way I chose the easy
way basically I encoded with cold you
could encode this using some
specification language may be an
interesting part here is that this
observation of the output value is
conditioned on the factor the queue is
empty or not so you know if the queue is
empty you don't want to look at the
value that is returned so that's why
this observation here is conditional
um no assertion so the assertion is is
the top idea that everything should be
sequentially consistent I see that
you're checking the dana fences in there
so that appears to be sequential yes you
can add assertions too I mean in every
practical verification project you will
want to add as many surgeons as possible
for that question if you want to check
that what you get out is what you can
put in you left with a state machine no
don't add a state machine so those this
is the the specification lining the
specifications generated automatically
from what you have already seen so the
reason is that if specified which of
food equals input well that the risk let
me say it this way so there are two
things you can do one is and this is
what we do in this demo there is no
specification of how the queue is
supposed to work except for the
implementation that we already have and
the idea is that if you take this
implementation and you assume that all
zeros executions are correct meaning
that the code you assume the code is
already correct if each operation is
executed atomically which is usually
true then you can take that as your
specification for the rest of the
executions this is what we do in this
demo in practice you may want to do
something else which is right a little
reference q you know five minute project
use that as your specification for your
concurrent q you would write this
basically the same things you have seen
here then you do a preliminary first run
which extracts the specification out of
your reference implementation and then
use this dead specification for the test
okay so now I just say compile and the
result is an intermediate representation
which I won't explain that i will show
you briefly so you know what's what's
going to happen and now it's time to
actually run the tool so I say check
fence I say which test I want in this
case it was t0 I have to say which
memory model so i start with sequential
consistency and of course they have to
input the code that i just compiled and
there it goes so you can see there are
two steps one was the specification
binding i'll talk more about that later
but they all well we'll give you a brief
overview second step is resolved past so
it works for sequential consistency now
what's good all executions are
observable its equivalent to some
sequentially consistent execution well
you would be another when we want a
little so so now i try a different
memory model and it fails so you know
what i said earlier is this thing has a
race condition i run it on a relaxed
very well i actually expect something to
go wrong and it did so now we have to
find out what is it that went wrong so
in order to look at this i actually copy
this to a public directory and look at
it with the browser
so here we are let me make this a little
bit bigger so this is the output that I
generated in HTML form and it takes a
little bit getting used to to browse
through these things without I'll give
you overview so we have two threads t1
and t2 t1 does the end cutie too does
the DQ we see the values that were used
so 0 was n cute then the result of the
DQ was one here meaning that it was not
empty but the value returned was
undefined so undefined is a value that I
loaded into memory locations that were
not loaded in the beginning of the test
case so what went wrong so now i look at
the thread t2 and it gives me a trace of
the execution of this thread so this is
not the actual source code if you step
through the source code with the
debugger you're used to seeing an arrow
advancing that doesn't work very well
for multi-threaded programs going on a
weak memory model because the error
would be all over the place it wouldn't
execute the instructions in sequence so
what I show instead is I show a trace of
what was executed of all the
instructions this line numbers tie back
to the C code and that you see a couple
things here I show in in purple I show
the value that was assigned in case if
it's an assignment or loaded and stored
I show in blue that the load or store
instructions that were part of this
instructions so sometimes there is more
than one load and store per line for
example here I load some value and then
it's stored here so that's why you have
both a load and the store in this
instruction the numbers next to the
loader store are the total sequence
number of that access so you know here
for example 34 means this load was you
know number 34 in the total sequence of
loads and stores so now we have a way of
finding out what went wrong looking at
thread to sew this undefined value came
from here was loaded by this load load
number 40 so I can click on that so this
gives me a slice of all accesses to that
one memory locations so I see there were
only two accesses to that memory
location and obviously this store is
probably what should have been loaded by
this load but it happened too late so
why does the store
until 8 i'll click on it get a view so
this is the store store number 48 this
is the store that stores the value that
is being an cute into the node and it
happened too late now this is happens if
you have worked this map relax many
months before this standard fail if you
write into a node and then you link the
node into the list you have to make sure
that this store happens before the node
is linked into the list so what you need
is you need actually a fence between
those stores so let me put that in my
daughter says what does the dual beam as
a figure so it looks at all executions
it looks at all observations that you
get from those executions so you can
think of all the symbolic values that
they had the arguments the return values
you think you can think of this as a
vector of values now for each vector
values you can decide is this a valid
the observation or not valid in the
sense that it corresponds to some serial
execution or invalid if it does not
correspond to serial execution what that
means is that the first time you ran the
tool will sequential consistency that
will basically evacuate because you're
saying that a su sequential consistency
and check for sequential consistency my
right and not cry but the ideas right so
the idea is that I run two times but I
don't compare sequential consistency and
relaxed I compare cereal and relaxed so
cereal means fully atomic so the entire
operation is atomic which is stronger
than two tests to ensure consistency
Lewis case you were comparing sequential
consistency and cereal in the second
case you are considering relaxed against
you yes conceptually you can compare
anything with anything because all you
do is you store the observations in a
set which i explicitly numerate and then
you run again and you can compare these
sets okay um
so now I have to introduce the fence
here
and I think because we're running at a
time I'll just you know tell you where
the other friends goes yeah so yeah this
is not the lock freak you that we had
earlier this is a queue with two logs
but it's not raised for you so it has
some optimizations but no it still has
log this common that you know it's yeah
okay so because I don't want to take too
long in this example I just put in
another friends that you know you would
find in another country example I'll
just put it in
up compile ms to
try this again so this time it passed
and of course we have we can try the
longer test so there was the test t1
which is just a bit a little bit longer
and i'll also try it a test that the one
that has four anchors and 4d cues which
really puts a little bit more stress on
the tool so this time it actually takes
a little longer they will not do all
this yep so isn't just for different
from the first two tests and that the
sequential Isis here to be common
threads instead of like eight yes so it
has it has more than one operation per
thread that's the difference creation
still tooth which yes so you get very
similar performance so what what happens
in if in this encoding I then use the
performance of the tool is very similar
if you have eight operations in a
threads or eight operations divided in
two threads interleaving doesn't matter
for this encoding not so much because I
have to tackle the fact that the memory
model does wild into leavings so because
I do that already how many threats you
choose is not such a big deal it matters
more how much instructions are in your
test so um yeah so it's still solving
thank you for the question during the
run that was great as a distraction I
don't understand also exactly what what
you are checking right so yes often in
ad in walk free code or when it's
paralyzed and results are okay they
differ it you just want to avoid race
conditions or or undefined us so these
are the race conditions here there are
intentional races here so you can't
check for avoiding race conditions in
this code what you want to guarantee is
that your data type looks like it's it's
everything is atomic you know you want
your
patience to appear like the atomic and
they're not interleaved at all to really
checking if there is a sequential
execution possible with this result set
your get exactly nothing always for the
same no not for the same all right ok so
this it passed which is good which means
I can stop this demo now go back to the
presentation
okay so now we want to i want to show
you a little more about how it works
internally so the core of this whole
tool is this part where we encode the
executions on a relaxed memory model as
a CNF formula conjunctive normal form so
the key idea here is to compile the code
into instruction sequences of finite
length for each thread and then i
represent the relative order of the
memory accesses using set variables yeah
and basically the memory model is
represented by an axiomatic
specification which i compile directly
into the sad formula I'll get into more
detail later this is the interesting
part really but i'll stay a little bit
on the surface for now so from CT c and
f it quite a long way to get from the
sequel to the actual formula so the
steps here are i start with the front
end which does a lot of work for me
which i'm very glad I don't have to do
all that work then there are some
interesting steps here where I go into
the intermediate language so one thing I
do is I maintain the tree structure of
the abstract syntax tree instead of
going to control flow graph the reason
is that when I'm unrolling the loops I
have much better control over all the
unrolling if my program has three
structure than if it has control flow
graph structure I represent pointers as
list of offsets rather than calculating
the actual number that corresponds to
the pointer and I use runtime types not
static types so in see the static types
are quite worthless because even if you
know what the type is in see it really
only tells you the bit width of your
thing everything else is a matter of how
the programmer uses it I want more
checking than without types so I do want
to check if you dereference a null
pointer I want to find out about that if
you want to find out if you do illegal
things with things so I can find a lot
of failures a lot better if I do not I
do not only do you know checking if
everything is equivalent to serial
executions I also check for a lot of
other clean nest properties that I have
these runtime type
and then I perform a range analysis
basically before I encoding to start
eagerly I want to know what are the
possible values of each assignment and
memory location and as I said earlier we
have all these interleaving zandri
orderings and thank God I can use a flow
insensitive static analysis and then
they don't care about into leavings at
all so that works nicely and because
everything is finite I can even make
that terminate so all of these things
are sort of interesting but I don't want
to make them the center of these talks
I'm going to go on to other things so
how do i get from c to c and f so once i
have my instruction streams for the
individual threads i do two things
separately i encode the thread local
semantics and i encode this
communication between threads those are
two different pieces of my start
encoding so for the thread local
semantics as i said we unroll the loops
and we get the final instruction
sequence for each thread after doing
that we use SAT variables to represent
all the values that appear in that
instruction stream and the outcome of
conditionals and we can create clauses
that express the computation that's
going on and how values flow within
threats yes you show you a roll lieut
three times oh ok I'll tell you on the
slide in about five slides from here ok
and then the second part is think the
communication between threads and I'll
talk about that later on because this is
where the memory model comes in yes sure
your analysis is based on uncie inputs
not nuts the output generated by some
compiler which could do ok so the
instruction requires in any Andrews
parks so is there something fundamental
rivets and take the output generated by
compilers or so that would be a very
good choice of something to do take the
output of the compiler use that as an
input for this too so the trade-off is
when you take the output of a real
compiler so i used i use more
abstraction a more abstract view of
what's happening in this NC with all the
things I said about like pointer keeping
list of pointers as offset also
manipulating individual pieces of a
machine word so all of these things are
a little bit harder if you do them at at
the actual output of a real compiler so
what I would do if I tried this I would
actually hack into the intermediate
representation in the compiler and do
this right before it generates the code
while I still have all this information
from the out of the high abstraction
level from this for source code so this
is it is about how how much over it need
your jus too yes sir I do i do try
really hard to make my encoding as you
know concise as possible and exploit
abstractions that are present in the
source code yeah ok so here comes the
questions about the look bones so i
clearly i do not know in advance how
many times i have to unroll the loops so
what I do is then I enrolled in once
then I run my tool check for errors
everything if I find errors I don't have
to enroll loops anymore I found an error
it's a sound counter example if there
are no errors I check if there are
executions that exceed the loop limit so
I basically run the stats over
specifically just to answer that
question and if I find the execution so
the loop limit is exceeded then I just
increase the loop limit and start over
and so for the for the examples we're
looking at here this process actually
terminates
because the loops inside those data
types do not look forever they are
bounded naturally with the fact that you
only call finitely many operations in
each test if it does not terminate it
usually the bog in which case you can
interrupt the process look at the trace
and find out why didn't it terminate yes
it's designed to be fair in the sense
you verify if there are two transactions
that are trying or stomp on each other
yeah so they have a variety of fairness
like definitions of different degree of
difficulty of implementation and
guarantee yes so there's obstruction
freedom there is weight freedom you
should see their clothes yeah so my tool
does not on work it does not support the
unrolling with the same concluding so
you really have to start over after you
enrolled more it's very hard so I think
it can be done I mean if I did if I
structured my whole encoding procedure
more cleanly and with that in mind I
could probably do it yeah so this is not
this will be an optimization of the tool
sure to do this sort of without starting
over so did you observe any examples of
data structures in which there's a bound
on the execution depth only if you
assume fear scheduling no I didn't see
that so basically you desperate
terminate regardless of the schedule yes
so for example one thing that could
happen potentially is that one friend if
you schedule it again and again it will
just spin around in a loop waiting for
some condition right evaluate to true
but that condition won't be said I true
until your schedule some other thread
first right so that's a against the
design principles that the designers of
these algorithms for low so they don't
want to write an algorithm that does
that because they want to guarantee you
some progress that's why I didn't take
that problem here there's one case where
it does have mitch's with locks
obviously if you have a spin loop that
rate still a lock is free that will be
an example so I handle that specifically
for locks so the spin loops in the lock
I dunno
unroll with these fans because that
would not terminate I mean what's gonna
happen with gas operations to and you
sit around the loop I'm castle but if
you pass if your cast fails yes it means
that you've interfered with somebody
else which means that somebody else made
progress so the next time you come
around to the same place that other
thread has made progress so somebody
makes progress every time it has fails
that's the kind of guarantee these
algorithms make yeah okay so we come
back to the specification Manning so i
said earlier that i basically enumerate
the set of valid observations before I
check so how do i enumerate all the
correct observations is actually not as
easy as just enumerate in all executions
because there are too many executions so
we actually use the fact that this is a
SAT solver and I can formulate
constraints to enumerate the valid
observations so I start with an empty
set of observations then I solve for a
serial execution meaning an execution
where all operations are atomic such
that the observed values are not
contained in my current observations in
and once I find that I added to the
observation set and I repeat this
process so basically every time I call
the SAT solver you know I wanted to give
me a new observation of fresh one so at
the end when I'm done I have when the
set services unsatisfiable and no we
have found all possible observations and
that's my observation set here so that
that you do that in the preliminary step
and then I take this when I verify the
executions on the relaxed model on the
sequential consistent model and check
that all executions you know everything
that observed set
and I want to compare this method to
something with it before so this is not
the only way you can do this so what we
did and we had this paper in we're going
to have this paper in pldi 07 we had
this paper last year where we used
commit points and I want to compare
these two approaches so what's the idea
of the commit points the idea with the
commit point is that there you have the
user tell the tool where does an
operation commit and a commit point is
just a logical point where this
operation takes place so if you have
several threads executing currently you
look at the relative order of the commit
point and it tells you the logical order
of the operations they're often
published along with the algorithm and
the reason why we abandoned this is that
it can actually be really complicated to
specify those commit points so while
they're a great tool if you're looking
at proving correctness of some
algorithms in an abstract way if you if
you actually have to annotate the commit
point in your code it gets really
difficult because you may need to use
facts about the execution that are
non-local to a particular threat in the
easiest case it's always the same
instruction but sometimes what happens
in other threads influences which of
your instructions is your commit point
so given that you know comparing those
two specification maintaining wins out
because it's more general and more
automatic and it turns out to be even
faster so there's really this point no
reason in this tool to use commit points
so I give a little runtime comparison
this is the exponential scale and both
compare each each bullet is individual
test case and basically if the bullet is
under the diagonal it means that the
specification writing is faster so you
see for all tests to specification
Manning was faster and to quantify that
these diagonal lines are constant rate
ratios so down here this is a ten times
improvement so that's an order of
magnitude there and the average was
about two point five nine
specification we're doing more work
faster so the reason is that for the
commit points I have to encode two
executions in the same set formula so
that the method with the commit points
encodes both the six serial execution
and the relaxed execution in one big sad
formula and that's just a much bigger
SAT instance to solve yes that's what
we're just well this is related but okay
go ahead so does the are you are you
including the time for finding out the
specific sure you do that absolutely
yeah okay I think if you're comparing
perhaps a little bit apples and oranges
here because the comic-con some sense
are part of the algorithm that you're
checking right if the correctness proof
of the algorithm depends on where you
place this commitment the second
specification lining you ignore this
coin yes and you so you have a more
liberal algorithm that's not sure it's
not well that depends on your standpoint
if you want to find out if your commit
points are right sure then you want to
specify the commitments and you want the
tool to report violations of the firm
eight points but in some cases you do
not know the commit points and then you
know you don't care about where they
would go you will just want to find out
is to result achieve but i agree with
you if you actually care about the
commit point for some other reason than
just correctness you know in this in the
sense that i'm checking then you might
want to annotate them okay so i give you
some related work here I won't talk
about it in detail I use the C
intermediate language CB MZ does a lot
of the same techniques and the
correctness conditions were elaborated
in this paper okay so I want to part I
will go on to the sort of theoretically
interesting part about this which is the
axiomatic concurrency model so I haven't
talked about the memory model up to this
point very much I just told you relaxed
memory models reorder executions split
instructions that's all I've said it
wasn't very precise so the reason was
that actually there is not just one
relaxed memory model
there are lots of them and all of these
architectures that our list here use
different ones and in order to deal with
that my approach is basically if you
verify the software you want to write it
for the worst possible machine so I did
derive a model called relaxed which is
weaker than all these models so if you
write code that works in this model you
know you got it right for all these
models so at the core of a sequential
consistency and I want to give you a
little more like a visual the views of
what happening in the memory model so
for sequential consistency we see
programs executing on two processors we
only care about the loads and stores at
this point and those loads and stores go
to a shared memory and conceptually this
is interleaved meaning that only one of
them you know can access memory at the
time gives us a natural interleaving of
these loads and stores now how do we
formalize that and this is really where
you can go different ways and you know I
think it's worth pointing out these two
ways because I think the community has
focused much more on the operational
model in the model checking world well
in the architectural world people have
focused much more on the axiomatic model
and I think there's something very
interesting in comparing those two so
I'm looking at the program here which
has two processors one does the store in
the low the one that's just the store
you can see that this load and this door
go to the same address now in the
operational model I model my the work my
executions are modeled by states and
transitions so you have an initial state
up here and my transition corresponds to
executing a single instruction at a time
so in basically at the beginning I can
either execute this instruction or this
instruction going two different ways
then here I have a choice of executing
instruction two or three and you can you
can see if you do one and three first or
three and one first they end up in the
same spot here but depending on if I do
to hear i get the zero because this
store hasn't happened yet well here i
get a 1 so this is standard standard
view of concurrent systems for model
checking
and for a lot of other things however in
the architecture world people look at it
a little different so the axiomatic
model basically does the following it
describes these instructions as events
so we have three different events it
describes the value that was loaded or
stored by event E as an entity V of E
and they have total order over all
events and then basically define what is
a valid executions by using axiom so I
say this set of events this valuation of
events and disorder represents a valid
execution if first of all one has to
happen before two because it's in
program order and secondly the value of
the load equals the last value store to
the same location and I can show you the
actual axioms that I use in my pool when
working with SC so this is the same
thing but now it's you know a little
more detail so I encode a set of
addresses values I have a set of memory
accesses and i categorize them into
stores and loads these are just subset
of all accesses and here is the memory
address and the value loaded by each
access furthermore I have a partial
order over those memory accesses p this
is the program order meaning that this
doesn't order all accesses but if to
access is happening the same on the same
processor then you know this represent
is represented by the fact that they
appear in a specific program order
there's also the memory order which is a
total order over all accesses and this
is actually the thing that is so
non-deterministic about the execution
now how do i define the axiom so in
order to define the axioms concisely I
say that I introduce this set s of else
set of stores that are visible to a
particular load by saying for each store
for each load the following stores are
visible its stores that have the same
address that go to the same address and
precede the load in memory order after
having said that I can now define the
executions as follows first of all if
things are ordered by program order they
have to be ordered the same way
by the memory order so this is saying
basically the memory order respects the
program order the second one basically
says loads get the value from the most
recent store expressing that and this is
expressed technically by saying loads
get the value out of the set of visible
stores that is maximal with respect to
the memory order yeah so okay I'll go
only things so now what's happening on
the relax no my mom so that was
sequential consistency what's going on
and relaxed memory models there are two
things so we have store buffers this is
the main relaxation for performance
reason the fact that the processor can
do is store and instead of committing to
the shared memory the store sits in the
queue in this queue it can be seen by
loads going from the same process so the
arrows here the arrows indicate the flow
of the data so you see that stores flow
this way and loads flow this way but if
a load hits in this store Q it will
actually get the value from here rather
from the shared memory so the takeaway
point is that stores happen locally
before they happen globally so there's
no atomic store anymore there's like a
local store happening immediately and
then a global store happening sometime
later well the other relaxation is that
the processor doesn't actually execute
the instructions in sequence but it's
more like this it has an instruction
window which I try to visualize here by
turning the program upside like to the
left 90 degrees and the processor sort
of opportunistically execute these
instructions in any order it sees fit
but that makes it possible to execute it
faster overall and the result is that
access is executed out of program order
subject to some restrictions so you
can't do that in all cases now how does
that influence the axioms I showed you
earlier so they're basically two
locations that I need to change first
here what are the store is visible to a
load I have to include stores that are
sitting in the local buffer but hat
don't have uh no comedic global yet
which means this set got just a little
bit bigger stores that precede the load
in program order always basically that
load even if they have
made it globally and and here I have
relaxation saying that in some cases
it's okay if the memory order does not
match the program order you know these
are just the specific conditions so you
can actually if you work through this
you'll see that this corresponds to the
relaxations we showed earlier but it's
tricky to to go through this anyway that
the good news is that once I have these
axioms i can actually compile these
axioms into my set formula so how does
it work so after doing all these
previous steps with the enrolling and so
on we know we have finite sets for
everything and after my range analogy
have finite ranges for values analyses
so I can really take these axioms and
compile them into that formula
specifically I used to represent this
memory order I take boolean variables
boolean variable mxy that represents you
know this ordering meaning i have a
quadratic number of variables and then I
extra I add constraints that force
sensitivity of that border ring usually
aggressive and that's the range analysis
idea flow insensitive analysis over all
the values of all the assignments in the
program and all the memory locations so
this is assuming that there is no
dynamic memory allocation no I have
dynamic memory allocation but again and
you know your program is unrolled and
finite so you only have a finite number
of places i gets dynamic analysis for
each and ruling yes up front ones no no
this is for after and roll okay yeah
yeah it's important point yeah it
wouldn't work yeah still be symbolic
great yes so they're symbolic in the
sense that there are set variables
symbolic Williams
but I do i do when i quote them into
that I do encode the cesspit vectors so
I have like a large bit vector
representing all possible values
precision is the number of the street
values right so I actually you know
there's a choice of how you want to do
this you could try to compact it into a
small bit vector as possible I do the
opposite and make a really large bit
vector but thanks to the range analysis
I'm able to fix like almost all parts of
the bit vector I can statically fix yeah
this is to this is the complexity of
your encoding reaction on the side but I
going to talk about also just curious
the complexity of the original program
for finite traces so you started by
saying I mean artisan checking
sequential consistency in general is
undecidable yeah for fine and Tracy are
you going to talk about that song no so
you know yeah I don't know what it would
be right I haven't thought about it yeah
okay and of course I have to support
fantasies and synchronization I used
classic load load load store store load
source or fences I also use some vika
forms of load load the advantage of
using these rico forms is that there are
no ups and some platforms so if I by
using the weakest possible friends in my
program I make it easier to take that
program and run it on a real processor
for example if my program only contains
store store and dependent load fences or
actually let's say store store and alias
load fences and I want to run this on
x86 then you know I don't need any
fences at all because those fences are
automatically guaranteed by that model I
also model synchronization by using
atomic construct so most of
synchronization operations are comparing
swap double components are blood links
their condition you can write code for
all of these using atomic sections yeah
in n square thank you just okay so yeah
the number of access is is a few hundred
now so I'm sure that later yes so you
have a relaxed memory model thank you
codex medical yeah what is the
complexity of encoding common practical
naked models such as x86 so that's third
the same so that there are only slight
differences doing the generalized like
every model is this goes and because I
don't want to debug my algorithm ten
times for ten different platforms I want
to get up get it right for me relax mode
and then having some value of pulling
that to other platforms it's more or
less straightforward as I said because
some things just fall out and other
staying yes it so many people come up
with these algorithms and they prove it
they prove it for some memory model or
they always assume sequentially
consistent platform so they stay away
from this problem with relax on it won't
be any fences in their algorithms so
they say things like you know in our
actual implementations he put in fences
but in order to find out where we just
tested it so that's as far as they go
but then it comes to sequential
consistency they prove that things are
correct the first thing is a section
just before related yeah
okay so but what does that say about the
previous slide okay so those are
basically two two different approaches
to you know the operational memory
models which work with explicit model
checking and this has been done this
works okay on small code snippets and
this is the approach that I'm taking
axiomatic model splits at service which
I think scales better but of course you
know you can always find examples that
work better for one or the other and
that this has the operational memory
models you know leave you this induction
over time that model checking gives you
so you get a in a different sense of
completeness if you actually do model
checking then if you need is bounded
test cases so you know both have their
value but then so we thought let me just
sort of summarize what the experience is
were so I studied the following our
Christmas these were all published you
know some of them pretty long ago 1996
some of them more recent so these are
all these are all you know distributed
algorithms conferences all of them have
some form of correctness proof and
that's interesting because some of them
had box even though they have redness
proofs so I found some regular box
meaning that box that also appear on
sequentially consistent memory models
the snark algorithm has two previously
known blog so i was i was taped off to
looking at this algorithm by a paper by
lan port which actually model checks the
snort algorithm and reproduces these box
the box were found by the original
authors so they must have after having
published an incorrect proved the most
of you know revised it and found the box
so one of the box is very easy to hit
the other one actually requires a large
test so this is a deck so i have pop
left and pop right so this was the test
that you used to find the bark which you
know it has eight threads and eight
operations i looked at the paper that
publishes you know the known bug the
notebook that they talk about uses seven
operations so i'm not that far away from
you know the best thing that fam but
this is interesting because you know i
can't come you and say small test cases
are always good enough to find the box
so here's an example
you really need a lot of operations did
you need as years eight trips or could
you have done with the same number of
operation and fuel rich so I didn't go
through the exercise of you know finding
the minimal text defined it so it's
possible possible to find it this year i
think but i'm not sure if there's fewer
than seven because i read the original
description of the book and it has a
scenario that requires at least seven so
it's rich yeah no not seventh right
story seven operations so the question
is for any shot if it manifests it's a
little in fridge no I think you're
absolutely right so the reason why I put
all these in different threads is not
because I need that many threats I need
that many operations and as i said
earlier my tool you know doesn't it's no
problem if there are eight threads it's
the number of operations that are
difficult so get more coverage by
putting them in different threads i also
found the book that was not previously
known in the lazy leave space set so
there was a missing initialization in
one of the fields and you know the
curiosity is that this was actually
formally verified with PBS it was you
know in last year's cat was actually the
talk right before my talk and and you
know what what does it tell us I mean
the proof is correct the problem is the
hand translation from the pseudocode in
the previous crib so when they
translated the pseudocode to PBS or
maybe even later on that they wrote to
see the code for the paper you know
there was a mismatch between the PBS
code and the source code basically
accidentally they fix the bug during the
translation is the global leader no
that's that's just a field in the node
so when you create an you know in Java
this is automatic you get all your
fields initialize when you create a new
object and see it it's not so it's right
at the border between what's the spells
you know so so the kind of thing that
you find when you when you automatically
translate your source code but you may
miss when you do some hand proof or some
more abstract proof and of course I
found many fails and relax mmmm also
this is standard these are not mistakes
in the
because these algorithms were made for
sequentially consistent models so I
inserted Francis by hand interesting is
I didn't need any store load or load
store fences so I think that's pretty
interesting it's interesting food for
discussion for people who are designing
you know the volatile semantics for c++
which is going on right now there was a
meeting between Microsoft IBM last week
and you know in terms of what fantasies
are important what fences should be
automatic in volatiles and what fences
should not be automatic also for deep
for finding these failures I did not
need these large chest cases so you know
you it all actually works a lot better
for this purpose which was the purpose i
designed it originally for here is
overview over the results 1 these are
the box that i found on SC defenses that
i inserted so i can i mean for each
fence i can show you a failing execution
of course you could agree or disagree
that this is the right place to put the
fence so it's not there is no automatic
fence placement you actually have to
know how the algorithm is supposed to
work in order to decide how to go
defense into fixing tool performance so
the thing to take away is just the scale
and these two sites this doesn't
actually matter so what you see is this
is a logarithmic scale and this is not
so the answer is it blows up on large
test cases but you can also tell that up
to hear it works really quite well she
does the number of memory accesses in
the unrolled code is a you know a few
hundred and the conclusion so the
conclusion is I successfully bridged the
gap so concurrent data types are hard to
get right there are mistakes and publish
papers and the tool was long overdue to
do this automatically the counter
examples are great to understand what's
going on in the memory models I can
handle a realistic level of detail it's
scalable enough for the example study I
wouldn't claim this to be scalable it
doesn't have the characteristics of a
scalable algorithm we don't need a
formal specification for the data type
that's kind of cool thats also about you
know what's confusing people like versus
specification so i think that's a nice
nice property of a tool that that it can
you sort of automatically get to
specification
and I think it makes the whole log for
eid a lot more realistic so without tool
it really takes a genius to get this
right or prove it right and visit tool
it takes an expert still not for
everybody I you know lock free
programming is very tricky now future
work so importantly I want to make the
tool publicly available so I have been
working with that but I need to document
more and needs to be packaged and
everything I want to support Vikram
memory models so there's the question
about supporting wild or architectures
like p p0 NT neum which makes liquor
guarantees in the memory model but
there's also the question is passing
directly to the language level memory
models like using java or c++ which i
think would be very interesting i think
there's a lot going to go on in this
area very soon and this is an
interesting point I've thought this chat
about that so taking these axiomatic
encodings and applying them to other
asynchronous verification projects like
cache coherence protocol would be very
interesting I think there's something
good to come from using these axiomatic
encodings to encode to concurrency vs
inter alia concurrency so the thing to
do here would be to take my global total
order of accesses and relax it to a
partial order like down in concurrency
theory and see if that can actually
improve the verification of asynchronous
so models I would also like to improve
the solver components so as I said
earlier magma encoding is cubic and
variables and quadratic in constraints
now that's only because the solver
doesn't support the theory of total
orders or the theory of pearl order
order so having us over supported
directly you know could cut back that
and could speed up the solving because
transitivity constraints could be
propagated much faster by specialized
theory then this is interesting
automatic fainting search and so this is
as I said earlier you can't relieve
insert defense is automatically because
camp you can suggest fences to a
programmer or you can help a programmer
I understand what's going wrong in an
execution because analyzing the counter
examples really is the hardest
hard at this point of using this tool I
would also like to develop reasoning
techniques for relaxed memory models so
you know after you have done all this
model checking at some point you would
really like to sit down and and prove
that it's true for all executions and
this is not even clear how to do and
relax many models people don't know how
to do that they haven't done it so that
should be done at some point and I would
also like to actually use the tool to
build a concurrent library so there's
nothing like using the tool to you know
making the dual truly better and that's
the end of my talk thank you for your
attention yes I can you come on top with
what scalability so for the experiments
and the example that you have considered
so far it sounds like your tool handles
them pretty well I mean you had this
logarithmic scale whereas there but
still thousand seconds okay so but so I
don't know that very at all but are they
very very large very very I mean you
just is this a sample the the set of
example you've considered is
representative or it's basically only
the simplest algorithm in that category
or I'd have extremely large lot free
implementation of they object using
libraries or basically or easily have a
Venetian of application where current
technology handles already has a ninety
percent of what's useful in there all
right so the examples are reasonable
algorithms so did the examples are
reasonable algorithms in the terms of
that there are greeted you know are very
complicated and what people actually
population and do of course when you go
to an actual implementation things are
never as clean as in this video code of
the paper so you will get a lot more
code in an actual concurrency library
then I looked at in these examples and
in that setting you would have to
develop a compositional way of verifying
them so what typically happens if you
write in actual library will reuse
pieces between different
patience and in order to do that
compositional which is the right way to
do anyway is you need to define a better
specification of concurrent api's than
we have currently so I think that's
something that that is really lacking in
concurrency libraries and actually
prevents writing concurrency libraries
for something like this is that you it's
actually not clear how to specify the
behavior of a concurrent data type on a
relaxed model like if you want to allow
some like leeway for the hardware to
relax things then you really have to
come up with a better way of specifying
tape specifying the behavior of your
data type I think that's actually
another future work topic to do yes so
you will need some with respect to the
input test cases you provide when you
reckon you write this symbolic test
cases and you only sound with respect to
those test cases yes so do you have some
insight on how to come up with these
test cases yeah so you know it's just
practical experience so I mean one thing
to do would be developed a coverage
criteria and then all the matter in
write these test cases you know to meet
that that would be a good project but so
far I can only have some you know basic
experience of using these test cases and
what I can say is that as I said for the
memory model related relaxations small
tests are easy and you can just put you
can just you know put one operation each
thread and run a number of threads and
you're very likely to hate it right away
it's definitely not necessary to craft
these tests so you don't have to go and
think very hard about what has to go
what should go wrong what could go wrong
by using a large number of threads and
putting you know all these operation
these threads it will find some into
leaving the finish the work
you